as the knights draw Reign and we
approach Halloween for many of us
there's nothing we like more than
getting cozy and settling down with an
absolutely terrifying blood curdling
horror game
but have you ever wondered why why do so
many of us enjoy the feeling of fear
well a team of researchers in Denmark
have been asking that very question and
even think that a bit of recreational
fear might be good for you previous
research on the psychology of horror has
focused on negative effects but we have
some studies that seem to suggest that
there may be positive effects and that
those benefits might actually outweigh
the negative
this is Matthias Clayson he's an
associate professor at arhus University
in Denmark and as you might be able to
guess from his backdrop he's a big
horror fan my professional interest in
horror really grows out of personal
Fascination I have these Vivid memories
of myself as a teenager reading a
Stephen King novel and being so freaked
out and yet I kept doing it night after
night I was enjoying it and I was
terrified but I also sort of stepped
outside of my own mind and asked myself
what's going on here there are many
misunderstandings about the psychology
of horror and the nature of horror fans
I wanted to know more that eventually
led me to do research on the phenomenon
matthias's interest in research led him
to create the recreational fear lab
which aims to find out why people enjoy
activities that give them feelings of
fear while that includes a lot of things
you might expect like horror games and
movies it also includes things like
extreme sports and even children playing
hide and seek unsurprisingly at the
recreational fear lab October can be a
busy month every year in October we do
haunted house studies where we put
together a research team and we travel
to our haunted house and we measure the
behavior and the physiology of guests in
a commercial haunted attraction there is
nothing like conducting Empirical
research against a backdrop of delighted
screams and chainsaws and the groans of
zombies a according to matthias's
research when we engage in recreational
fear by walking through a haunted house
or playing a horror game we're buying
into a kind of make-believe world full
of cues that activate biological
responses evolved over millions of years
that's why when you're playing a horror
game your palms get sweaty your heart
beats faster and jump scares make you
leap from your chair
you're putting your body into a state of
fight or flight and it's reacting as
though those cues are coming from real
dangers but and this is the key part
because we know it's not real we can
instead enjoy the rush of Sensations we
get from activating those biological
responses and practice our coping
strategies for scary situations as a
kind of play what Matthias and his team
have found through their research is
that there is a kind of inverted
u-shaped relationship between enjoyment
and fear levels if the the fear level is
too low it's a weak boring but if it's
too scary it's not enjoyable either this
means that there's a sweet spot for
every individual the just right amount
of fear in order for them to have a good
time this relationship is a lot like the
one we see with the feeling of flow
check out our previous episode of the
show all about that and much like flow
video games offer the player a great
opportunity to balance their levels of
fear and enjoyment I can't influence the
the way the story unfolds when I'm
watching a horror movie or reading a
book but when I'm playing amnesia the
Dark Descent I can decide not to go into
the room from which a weird noise comes
and so that feeling of agency that
feeling of being able to influence what
happens leads to a higher degree of
presence of investment and because it's
pretend because there is no real risk no
real danger we can reap the benefits we
can get all the pleasure out of playing
with Danger
fun is certainly well fun but matthias's
research has shown early indications
that engaging with horror media could
actually have beneficial effects that
stretch Beyond simply having a good time
while you're scaring yourself silly most
previous research on the psychology of
horror has focused on negative effects
media psychologists spent a lot of time
especially back in the 80s looking into
how kids would get nightmares from
watching Poltergeist or Gremlins or Jaws
but we have some studies that seem to
suggest that there may be positive
effects and that those benefits might
actually outweigh the negative one study
in particular by Matthias and his team
examined the mental health impact of the
covid-19 lockdowns in March and April of
2020. their hypothesis was that during
this time where everyone was in a state
of anxiety and Dread horror fans might
be coping better having exercised those
coping strategies for scary situations
through engaging with horror media so we
found actually that horror movie fans
had better resilience they reported
fewer stress symptoms fewer troubles
sleeping fewer concentration issues than
non-fans probably because they have had
more exposure to fear stimuli in a kind
of playful setting and they were able to
to take that practice that expertise if
you will and apply it in a real world
context so that's one example of
of a positive effect of recreational
fear this idea of taking stress
management techniques learned in a
recreational setting and applying them
to real-world stress opens up the
potential for horror games to be used as
a kind of treatment tool a controlled
virtual version of exposure therapy
thanks to their immersive potential the
use of video games and VR games for this
purpose has prompted an exciting New
Branch of psychological research looking
at the ways video games can be used to
help people practice their fear and
anxiety responses in a more controlled
way one such study is by Lucy Daniel
Watanabe a PhD student at the University
of Cambridge who is working with games
developer Ninja Theory as part of their
Insight project researching how to use
Game technology to reduce anxiety
symptoms one thing that we've been
looking at is using virtual reality to
simulate some experiences that people
might find anxiety-inducing we try and
teach them a breathing technique in a
boat experience and you're trying to
breathe very slowly and regularly to
reduce your heart rate and then we put
them in a stressful situation which is
the dungeon
and in the dungeon there's a monster
pulling around and they are told that
their best way to avoid being detected
by monster is to keep their heart rate
low by practicing the breathing
technique they just learned in the book
you can tell someone to do a breathing
technique you don't really have any way
of making them do it next time they are
actually stressed what we're trying to
do with virtual reality is both teach
people these techniques and then
immediately have them apply it to
something that is stressful and the hope
is that by doing that they can then take
that back into the real world and apply
that to the stressful situations there
this dungeon in Lucy's simulation might
seem outlandish but in this instance
having stereotypical horror imagery to
draw on was useful previous tests
playing on more mundane phobias like
spiders public speaking or Heights
prompted very varied results depending
on the individual's tastes though it's
somewhat of a generic horror scenario it
seems that a monster looming overview is
more of a universal fear and more likely
to induce the response they're looking
for plus it gives Ninja Theory a bit
more license to stretch their creative
muscles
what I hope is that we can use gaming
technology more in psychiatric research
because I think it is a really
interesting Avenue for a lot of the
things we try and accomplish in
Psychiatry and psychology which is
eliciting specific emotions and
responses from people specifically for
my research what I'd really like to do
is I'd like to create something that can
be used to teach people to control their
physiological responses and stressful
situations so teaching people how to
when your heart is racing calm it down
so does this mean everyone should be
playing horror games as a way to sort of
inoculate yourself against world events
well probably not as we said earlier
everyone's individual fear tolerance
will be different so maybe your fear
tolerances Animal Crossing you do you
foreign
that said Matthias is optimistic about
the potential uses of horror video games
in future research as they provide a
virtual repeatable safe way to prompt
fear responses in study participants
there's even the possibility of a
mutually beneficial relationship where
psychologists benefit from using horror
games in studies and game developers
benefit from the findings the
researchers uncover in order to create
more individualized horror experiences
there may be a future in which game
designers and scientists could work more
closely together to maybe harness some
of the benefits of recreational fear
maybe design games that are really good
at letting players find that sweet spot
of fear and so develop that coping
potential maybe the future will bring
horror video games where your current
fear level can be measured by heart rate
and the video game detects your fear
level and it sees okay this guy playing
Amnesia is too afraid I need to turn up
the light inside the game or you know in
Reverse he's beginning to be bored let's
turn up the fear jets that would be a
very useful way of applying that that
finding I think maybe we can look
forward to a future where horror games
are not only designed to push your
personal fear tolerance but maximize the
potential psychological benefits of
playing them too we may be somewhere off
a doctor prescribing the latest horror
Blockbuster as a mental health treatment
but if you enjoy them a scare or two
might be good for you but what about the
developers of horror games what
techniques do they use to scare players
and what do they themselves find scary
over the next few weeks on Mind Games
we'll be speaking to a number of horror
developers to find out how some of the
biggest horror games hope to get inside
our heads and stay there long after we
stop playing until next time
sleep time